like any passionate chef i want the best
ingredients i can find whether it's for
savory
or sweet dishes
next up my guide to buying chocolate
chocolate gives you such an instant hit
it's well worth knowing about the good
stuff
and who better to ask than award winning
alchemist of the sweetest kind paul
young even when i don't want to think
about it i'm thinking about it
his cutting-edge approach to chocolate
making has won him accolades around the
world
so when you're not shopping the best way
is to look at your chocolate bar look on
the back and look at the percentage that
gives you how much cocoa is in the bar
and the more cocoa the more rich
intoxicating flavor
so the most exciting bit is tasting
chocolate
good quality fine chocolate should have
that clean snap bite a piece off
and crunch it in your teeth
but stop chewing
let it melt
move it around the mouth and you'll find
that by letting it melt
even dark chocolate that you've had
before
that seems quite bitter won't be when
you chew quickly it releases tannin it
releases all the bitterness in the
chocolate letting it melt it's smoother
and richer and you get all the flavor
and most excitingly is it releases
something into the brain called dopamine
which makes you feel good and that's how
you get addicted to real chocolate
chocolate is not just an addictive treat
it's an amazing ingredient here's my
take on which kind to use for what
[Music]
white chocolate with its sweet vanilla
taste it's perfect used as a dipping or
pouring sauce with fresh fruit or frozen
berries for a quick dessert
creamy milk chocolate is great for
family friendly puddings and treats like
quick bake cakes or melt onto homemade
crepes or waffles
dark chocolate is rich and intense i
like using 70 cocoa stuff use it for ice
creams that really pack a punch
100 pure cocoa has a very powerful
intense taste and only the real
chocolate geeks eat it straight and
remember chocolate isn't just for sweet
dishes for the famous mexican morally
sauce this is the one to grab
is there anything better than chocolate
they say sex but that's totally
overrated
my next recipe will be right up your
alley
malt chocolate doughnuts street food is
all about satisfying your cravings these
donuts are sweet sticky and absolutely
delicious
first off we're gonna make the dough
now
this dough takes a bit of time
but it's really exciting
i'm heating all of the milk with the
sugar
this yeast
easy to get hold of now when you make
fresh doughnuts
you need fresh yeast
adding some of the warm milk to the
yeast will activate it which will help
the dough to rise
just half
give that a quick whisk
the sugar is dissolved in the milk
the fresh yeast disintegrates instantly
set the yeast mixture to one side while
it does its job
to start the main dough mix i'm adding
half the butter to the remaining milk
that gives the dough a nice silkiness i
want it light
so melt the butter into the milk
flour
into a sieve that helps to make the
dough nice and smooth and you know what
when you've got a smooth dough
it sort of rises evenly
add a pinch of salt and two egg yolks
pour in the warm milk and melted butter
don't start over mixing it
when you over mix
the dough of the doughnut it gets really
tight you're not gonna let it ariel
yeast in
nice and warm
i love that smell
now i'm looking for a sort of elasticy
texture
just dropping off the spoon
nice flour the board
take the dough out
lovely
lightly sprinkle a touch more flour
and just pull it over and push in
every time you're sort of turning it
almost like you're turning the dough
into itself the dough should just sort
of relax
and it shouldn't be sticking to your
fingers now it's just nice and pliable
set that in a nice clean bowl
a little sprinkling
flour in there so as it starts to rise
it doesn't stick
cover that with same film
leave the dough to rise in a warm place
for 60 to 90 minutes until it's doubled
in size this stage is called proving
now whilst that's proving get a
panel for the chocolate filling or
ganache pour 500 ml of double cream into
a saucepan and add honey
[Music]
bring the mixture to a gentle boil
[Music]
traditionally we've always put jam in
there but chocolate and donuts wow to
die for
add the cream
i'll give that a good mix
the butter elevates the ganache into a
really nice shiny chocolate coat
look at that whoa
give it a really nice whisk
the whistling gives it that aerated
texture to the ganache you're just
lightening the load a little bit
nice
chocolate filling done
put it in the fridge to cool then it's
time to gently roll out the dough
just let it roll naturally
about a centimetre and a half
in depth
slice
one
two
place them on it's your tray
and let them rise again
once the donuts have had 30 to 40
minutes to rise it's time to shallow fry
them in a pan filled one third full with
hot vegetable oil
risen but look they're sort of
like little pockets of air
right here we go
place these in nice and carefully
four maximum if there's too many in the
pan the oil will go cold and the donuts
will come out soggy
turn them over
beautiful
we're gonna come out into some sugar
mixed with some malt powder
50.
how do you tell they're actually cooked
in the center
tap on top it should be hollow
in
and just sprinkle
the malt
and the sugar shake off
the excess i get so excited every time i
make donuts
now
look at those beauties
these are delicious eating as they are
but the ganache is gonna be the icing on
the cake
piping bag
peel the bag
over your hand
don't forget to pop the nozzle in
i want the
texture almost like a little liquid
inside
so i'm going to pipe them with a little
bit warm hopefully you've got that burst
of magic
operation donut
lift up
the donut squeeze push in and fill
just to start seeing that chocolate
coming out
and sit that back down
nice
sit them on there
they've got a little bit heavier
and we all know why
nice
that one's got my name on it
that is amazing
[Music]
you